much to our coverage now of the  coronavirus today the fda started  discussing booster shots for the moderna  and johnson and johnson coronavirus  vaccines over the next two days the  agency will vote on the two options  today is moderna in the spotlight u.s  surgeon general dr vivek murthy says  today is really just the beginning of a  long process the advisory committees  provide advice but ultimately it is the  agencies themselves that will make the  final decision we should generally  whenever we can try to follow the advice  of the fd and the cdc here because they  are looking at the totality of the data  meanwhile preliminary data shows people  who got the one dose j j vaccine might  be better off with a booster from one of  the other vaccines seven million  americans have already received a pfizer  booster shot